tous annoncé comme un voyage normal pour
patrick et sébastien le 6 mars dernier
le couple s'envole vers mis à me
rejoindre des amis avant de se rendre au
texas pour un anniversaire au québec
avait un corps en floride avait deux
corps au texas avait un corps dont les
probabilités de contagion me semble bien
mince innocemment
mais voilà on est quand même parti c'est
à leur retour le 16 mars que tout
bascule
quel pendant la nuit on a fait une
fièvre très très très grosse fièvre puis
c'est parti
éloquent sa part cette loge sport ça
vient par vagues
c'est très très difficile au début
j'avais pas de tout le mal aux muscles
j'avais ma la poupe
je suis maintenant que j'aime le matin
c'était difficile tout est difficile
et à cause de la fièvre on se déshydrate
ça donne aussi de la fatigue la
léthargie
ce qui est beau du tout apprécié j'ai
commencé à boire tout comme vous voyez
je trouve pas mal mais bon ça c'est vrai
j'ai pas beaucoup de force pour vous
répondre mais je suis que vous sachiez
que je lis vos messages c'est très
encourageant
sébastien était trop malade pour nous
parler aujourd'hui c'est par
l'intermédiaire des réseaux sociaux
qu'il tente de rassurer sa famille et
ses amis pour mon copain c'était violent
dès le départ lui est alité depuis
presque jo photomarathon l'an dernier le
liard été moins pire mais jusqu'à donner
à remonter les marchés montent à une ère
fois une fois je pose juste une grille
même une vraie maman va durer cinq jours
ce jour de sa fête 10 les deux hommes
peuvent compter sur leurs proches un
soutien moral essentiel durant cette
période où la peur de mourir a même
traversé leur esprit de deux jours j'ai
préparé la valise l'on pourrait appeler
le 9-1-1 au cas où mon conjoint a une
moins bien mais pas très garde espoir un
espoir par contre fragile puisque son
état tarde à s'améliorer
les pleurs du même coup la population à
respecter les consignes de distanciation
sociale et d'isolement six mois on met
mon copain on est des personnes très
enfants avant la maladie pions s'offre
aux terres je ne vois pas comment les
personnes déjà un peu souffrir devant on
réussira passe à travers c'était dur ici
marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal